[Music]
alexandria is with us in canada hi
alexandria how are you
hi i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so my question for you is around
housing i'm willing to move but having a
difficult time deciding what to do
um i'm 28 years old i'm from vancouver
canada i recently graduated with my
degree so i made 40 an hour now
um i've been living on my own for 10
years but before now i've never made
more than 35 000.
i live in a very small dark basement
suite there's no natural lighting but
it's what i could afford while i was in
school
my rent was 50 of my income before 25
now
but my housing situation is having a
negative impact on my mental health
um again it's just very dark and small
and it's really negatively impacting me
but i am not able to find anything else
that seems
like a smart choice financially the
cheapest basement suite i can find right
now is 1300 i currently pay 9.80
moving to a different town seems silly
because i make as much as you can make
with my degree
and so if i moved somewhere else i'm
likely to make less money
i tried to get pre-approved for mortgage
but my finances weren't high enough i
haven't made enough money
and so i just don't really know what to
do i feel like i'm stuck between a rock
and a hard place i can't find a rental
that's feasible i can't buy where i'm
living right now is really
making my mental health suffer and yeah
i just don't know what to do
so why are you looking at basement
suites have you looked at just an
apartment she lives in a basement yeah
but you said you looked at another one
and there are 1300 yeah i mean
it's all the same
i would live anywhere okay
well
you make 40 an hour do you have any debt
um so i have student loans taken out and
i have 31 000 but i also have the full
amount sitting in an investment right
now
um so like in a brokerage account
non-retirement
yeah yeah so i have 35 595 in my in my
uh investment right now and i owe thirty
one thousand six hundred eighty one
dollars in student loans i have like
four thousand technically that's mine
if you actually you're going to cash out
and pay those student loans off today
i know that's what you would teach but
the investment's getting really low
but you're broke
i'm confused why did you call us for
help if you don't do what we teach
um because
i i'm really interested in your advice
about my housing situation specifically
well the housing situation gets tied
into your debt and how much money you
have and how much margin you have could
you afford this 1300 in rent if you
didn't have any debt
um no even if i paid the student loan
back i think i'd still be in the same
position because i'm just basing it off
my income only would you be willing to
get a roommate
i've had roommates before
until the last year i've lived on my own
for 10 years and i'm just really feeling
like at this point in my life i need to
prioritize living on my own to ensure
that i prioritize my wellness
i've lived with over like 40. well let
me help you being broke is going to mess
with your wellness too
yeah it is
so something's got to give here
you can't just make up your own rules
and call it wellness um you know you
can't you get you if you want to move
out of the basement i don't really blame
you for that
but you're probably going to have a
roommate or you're going to move to a
different city and you're going to
investigate what you can make in a
different city where there's a lower
market with real estate but probably a
lower market on wages is not necessarily
wrong what's your degree in
child and youth care counseling so it's
similar to social work yeah yeah well it
probably will not be dramatically
different if you move to a real estate
market that is way cheaper i don't let's
say 25 cheaper i doubt your wages
dropped 25
in that marketplace so i think you
investigate working in a different city
that's less expensive vancouver is one
of the more expensive cities in the
world
i mean you're talking like new york city
here
chicago miami these are these are you
know la san francisco vancouver it's on
the list toronto right
these are major metropolitan centers in
the world and very very expensive to
live in and child care and social work
area is probably very difficult to make
a go with that so you get to decide
which of these things you're not going
to do
but you can't do all of them just
because you want to
so i'm not gonna live in the basement i
am gonna have a roommate and i am gonna
move
or i'm not gonna live in the basement
and i'm not gonna have a roommate and
i'm gonna move even further out
you get to decide but you don't get to
make math up
because you ha and call it wellness
because being broke is also going to
affect your wellness your mental health
it's stressful it's unbelievably anxiety
ridden there's all kinds of problems
around it so
you know i don't blame you for wanting
to move out of the basement but you
can't put 73 boundaries on all this
decision and still end up with a smart
decision that's what your pinch is
and you called up wanting our advice on
stuff when you already don't take our
advice which is also illogical
so i don't know why our advice on real
estate works when it doesn't work on the
other stuff so pay your stupid student
loan off get a roommate and move to a
real community but you're probably not
going to do any of those yeah and i'm
doing the math here dave and if she's
making 40 bucks an hour and she's
working full-time that's about 76 grand
a year so even after taxes she can
afford a 1300 apartment if she got out
of debt and if she had her money back
with her
but she's doing it her way with her own
plan
and uh i wish her the best
but it's not gonna work out and the
wellness part like you're mentioning the
best thing you can do for self-care is
get yourself debt free
well and and start putting reasonable
boundaries in your life that are doable
uh you know open loops are what bring
anxiety meaning un
decisions that are not made
decisions where you leave things hanging
in your brain that you don't have a loop
on you haven't closed the loop on it
you've made the call is is the
ambivalence is much more stressful than
actual hard times
so pick your pain
you're going to have a roommate you're
going to move to a rural area you're
going to live in a basement
pick your pain
because one of them's coming darling
oh the third one is financial problems
pick your pain
one of those four is coming to you
you probably ought to decide that on
purpose
that's what i would do
it's a lot less stressful a lot better
for your wellness
this is the ramsey chef